they were so young and so happy
[Music]
their family simply can't understand why
anyone would want to hurt them
one-year-old Neymar and her
three-year-old sister Fatima died soon
after the fire their mother who'd been
on life support has also now passed away
it means this is now a triple murder
investigation behind the blackened
Windows of their first floor flat in
Nottingham police work goes on neighbors
who knew the family are at a loss
and things like that the kids always
said hello not me to me they didn't have
a full bone in the body so I don't know
who would want to do this
They're All Dead sad about it obviously
you know what I mean but they were a
lovely family
the family were most likely fast asleep
as their flat filled with smoke in the
early hours of Sunday morning
investigations so far have led police to
conclude that it was started
deliberately
detective Chief Inspector Mark sinsky
who's leading the investigation said
we're dealing with one of the most
horrendous crimes the death of two young
children and their mother this is a
deeply upsetting tragedy and I can only
imagine the family's pain they include
the woman's husband and the father of
the two children who was not in the UK
at the time of the fire this has been an
extremely traumatic event for them and
I'd like to reassure them we're doing
everything we possibly can to bring them
the Justice they deserve
among those leaving flowers was
three-year-old China she was in Fatima's
class at Nursery too young to understand
what happened she drew a picture for her
friend
the police say they're keeping an open
mind about the motive for these murders
and have a large team following several
lines of inquiry
officers have been given more time to
question the 31 year old local man they
have in custody
the question is why this young family
were targeted Becky Johnson Sky News
Nottingham